[Music]
americans held hostage behind enemy
lines day 52
all right welcome to hannity sadly day
52 biden's state department is quote not
in a position to say as of yet how many
americans remain trapped behind enemy
lines hostage to the taliban they have
no clue they have no earthly idea joe
biden abandoned them and by the way the
media mob they just ignored the story as
if it didn't happen imagine if this
happened and donald trump was president
there are zero over the horizon
capabilities to get them out all this
leverage joe biden claimed that he has
he has none it's been nearly 35 days
since joe biden even mentioned these
americans he's abandoned according to a
breaking report from the new york times
scores of c.i.a assets in afghanistan
and around the globe they have been
captured they have been killed or they
have been compromised make no mistake
all caused by joe biden and all
completely preventable and by the way
and he does as
john andrastic's song says
joe biden has blood on his hands joe's
cowardice on the world stage will haunt
this country and the world for years to
come who will trust us again
look at the the aggressive nature of
china in taiwan today
he didn't even help his own fellow
americans he's not going to help you
they're sending a message loud and clear
that they're emboldened today as a
result of joe biden and biden today is
not thinking about those that he left
behind in afghanistan never mentions him
he's not thinking about the crisis at
our southern border never mentions it
truth be told biden probably doesn't
even form many cogent thoughts anyway
but his staff did send him off to
michigan today to give a speech about
his
3.5 trillion dollar build back better
socialist spending uh disaster which is
now stalled in congress thankfully and
caused causing a democratic civil war
needless to say
oh speech didn't particularly go well
not hard to predict take a look
and by the way parenthetically when you
build a charging station it's like back
in the day when my grandpop worked for
the american oil company back in the
tournament in the 1999
in that area they went from state to
state convincing people that they put
allow them to put 20 000 gallons of
gasoline under the ground they didn't
want them around but guess what happened
everything builds up around them you put
these charging stations along how are
you going to see a significant economic
development go well beyond the charging
station
all right what on earth is joe biden
actually trying to say here um you know
he's no donald trump notice he doesn't
get big crowds a lot of people doesn't
seem to make a lot of sense and he
mumbles a lot he fumbles a lot he
bumbles a lot and frankly i don't even
think he knows what he's reading on that
teleprompter regardless he's desperately
trying to save this insane domestic
socialist agenda why because his radical
party is demanding it pelosi zero
control over her caucus her instincts
would be get as much as you can and let
me go back to san francisco and let me
eat a lot of designer ice cream but
anyway she's getting rolled by the
devout socialists in her base and as
i've said many times before the real
speaker of the house that would be
alexandria ocasio-cortez frankly it's a
humiliating culmination of nancy
pelosi's what
3582 years in the washington swamp and
now of course with the stalled agenda
the radical left they're implementing
one of their favorite tactics mob rule
their victim latest victim senator
kristen cinema one of two democratic
senators that refused to rubber stamp
this 3.5 trillion dollar socialist
welfare madness yeah she's now getting
stalked all over the country we told you
about last weekend in arizona you got a
group of deranged left-wing activists
illegal immigrants harassing and filming
the senator filming the senator
while she's in a stall
in the ladies room now just stop for a
minute and ask yourself
what would the reaction of the mob and
the media be and the democrats if it was
a trump supporter with a maga hat on why
is that allowed to happen and where are
the democrats sticking up for her biden
pelosi schumer you're going to stand up
to your for your own colleagues being
stalked and harassed now daily i doubt
it because you're probably afraid of
their radical socialist base you're
afraid it's going to happen to you and
pelosi speaker in name only schumer well
he only answers to bernie sanders joe
biden the biden bernie manifesto he
doesn't even know what the hell is going
on and as a result we you the american
people and frankly the entire world is
suffering at the border where joe biden
should be today a crisis continues to
spiral out of control there listen to
this according to former border patrol
chief
rodney scott he just retired in june 30
years of service terrorists from around
the globe they are now attempting to
capitalize on all of this chaos
something we have been warning you is
likely true that you will have people
that have agendas to bring harm to this
country and we're not vetting them we
don't look and see if they have radical
associations we're not even giving them
covert tests and guess what they get
preferential treatment and they don't
even get a vaccine mandate they just get
a here will you please show up but we're
only requesting you don't have to take a
look
we have nation state threats we have
terrorist threats we can't get into in
this type of a forum but they're real
they exist and they want to come across
that border statistically it always
includes rapists murderers potential
terrorists every single year if you look
at cbp statistics publicly available
those all exist in who we actually catch
as i've said many many times this is a
national security crisis it is a
humanitarian crisis it is a health
crisis of course in the middle of a
pandemic come here legally i don't care
where you come from legally respect our
laws borders and sovereignty we need to
know you don't have radical associations
we need to know in the middle of a
pandemic you're healthy and that you
won't be a financial burden to the
american people if you have that
background check you do it legally
welcome to our country and i don't care
where you come from and yet joe biden he
won't even visit the border in fact he's
never ever visited the border not a
single time not once as a senator not as
vice president not as president and he's
been in the swamp 8
927 years he's been there longer than
pelosi and now because joe is unable and
unwilling to secure the borders a group
of republican governors they're not
having to do his job step up to the
plate but they can't enforce the laws
that he won't enforce because he's
aiding and abetting the law breaking you
can't make this adam schiff up take a
look
we have a crisis at our border
unprecedented heartbreaking and
completely avoidable
and to understand the magnitude you need
only look at the numbers
when joe biden took office he
immediately stopped construction of the
border wall since then there's been a
surge of immigrants flooding our
southern border
border apprehensions are up 500 percent
and border patrol facilities are beyond
max capacity investigative journalist
and reporter sara carter will follow
these governors as they tour the border
we'll have full coverage tomorrow night
right here on hannity now if joe biden
had any decency at all well he'd head to
the border let him talk to the people
that live in border communities let let
him hear from them how hard this has
been on them let's look at the cost why
is joe biden giving preferential
treatment to people that don't respect
our laws
our borders our sovereignty but joe
biden well he is who he is he's a liar
he's a con man a plagiarist and has been
his entire life well he's just maybe a
slight bit better than zero experience
hunter only difference now is joe is in
a very steep cognitive decline he is
cognitively weak he is frail anyway his
dishonesty and incompetence is now more
obvious than ever and now democrats are
rightfully very worried about the
midterm elections in 2020